et puis on parlait des personnalités
autour de lui tout à l'heure et bien
l'élection de nicolas sarkozy aura
certainement une conséquence sur l'exil
de johnny hallyday dont on a beaucoup
parlé
johnny hallyday qui était à ses côtés
dimanche soir son épouse laeticia
annoncé ce matin sur rtl qu'il
reviendrait certainement s'installer en
france
explication martin gouès daniel lévy de
retour d'exil fiscal dès dimanche soir
johnny hallyday se montrait comme un des
premiers supporters de nicolas sarkozy
les colas sarkozy tiendra parole
j'en suis certain j'en ai encore parlé
avec lui tout à l'heure il tiendra
parole
il y a cinq mois la famille hallyday
décidé de quitter la france direction la
suisse
le motif le chanteur verse trop d'argent
à l'état aujourd'hui on est ici à l'idée
annonce le retour on va certainement
revenir en france puisque est
aujourd'hui là la fiscalité en français
est inacceptable travailler les trois
quarts de l'année pauvres pour l'état
c'est pas possible
ce qu'on vous a fait perdre de plus
précieux cher johnny ce qui va changer
c'est le bouclier fiscal c'est à dire le
montant maximum de l'impôt versé à
l'état
il existe depuis le 1er janvier dernier
il est de 60 % des revenus
s'y ajoute les contributions sociales
nicolas sarkozy veut un bouclier fiscal
à 50% tout compris c'est à dire qu'on ne
paiera pas en impôts directs csg crds
inclut plus de la moitié de ce que l'on
gagne un seuil psychologique
la politique de monsieur sarkozy qui est
dire même si vous gagnez très bien votre
vie on ne prendra pas plus de 50% de ce
que vous gagnez et qui de consentir à
donner l'autre moitié
je pense que psychologiquement c'est
rassurant et que ça conforte un petit
peu dans l'activité professionnelle
qu'on est amené à développer tous les
jours dans le calendrier prévu par le
prochain chef de l'état le bouclier
fiscal nouvelle version devrait passer
devant le parlement à l'automne et
s'appliquer le 1er janvier 2008